en términos prácticos Qué significa el
retiro de hinche de sus votos si podrían
sumarse a los de quemal Kids el
principal candidato opositor
Hola Valentina Muy buenas tardes
efectivamente
una de las señalamientos que hizo el
propio inché cuando fue cuando hizo su
anuncio que estaba dejando su
candidatura era porque estas acusaciones
que habían venido de parte de la
oposición de que él en primer lugar
estaba trabajando a favor del del
oficialismo a favor de erdogan
restándole votos
aglu y de esta forma iba a arrestar
poder a su campaña no que suena y que en
estos momentos es la que va en primer
lugar en las
encuestas de salida no de esta forma
la salida de inchet definitivamente
va a galvanizar seguramente la
campaña de
y va a favorecer a a sus votantes no la
idea es que los votantes de hinche o
estos
personas que iban a votar a favor de él
vayan a a esta hacia el voto de quemado
Bueno y qué significaría una derrota
para erdogan que ha causado que un
opositor según son dedos tenga mayor
intención de Voto
pues definitivamente las razones la
primera que podemos encontrar es la
economía no la situación que estamos
trabajando en todo el mundo y en el caso
de Turquía ha sido muy notable los
niveles de inflación está muy altos la
gente lo está viviendo día a día no
definitivamente las acusaciones de
corrupción y sobre todo de un estado
pues sumamente autoritario han sido sus
puntos más débiles y Bueno
definitivamente la respuesta que ha
tenido el gobierno ante el terremoto de
febrero también ha sido puntos más
débiles sobre los cuales ha sacado la
oposición al gobierno de erdogan no por
otra parte
ha señalado
estos puntos muy fuertes en su campaña
no acercarse a la gente promover una
economía distinta también un
acercamiento mayor a occidente
seguramente No retomar la iniciativa de
la integración a la Unión Europea y
voltear a ver a los jóvenes lo cual
también es muy importante en este caso
Hay algún movimiento alianza que le
quede a una para fortalecer su posición
y ganar votos solo a tres días de los
comicios
a tres días parece muy muy improbable
que esta situación vaya a cambiar todo
apunta no a que
la alianza es muy fuerte está cerca del
49% de la intención de Voto recordemos
que es habrá un habría una segunda
vuelta si no logra más del 50% de los
votos dentro de 15 días
Parece ser que se ha quedado no sin
aliados y sus clásicos aliados sobre
todo aquí tenemos que tomar en
consideración una una parte muy
importante de la votación que son los
jóvenes no más de cinco millones de
jóvenes van por primera vez más de 13
millones son menores de 25 años es decir
toda su vida han estado prácticamente
bajo el régimen de erdogan Probablemente
sean los principales
intencionados en hacer un cambio de
régimen